the jurgen experience there was a thing
about golfers i was like these guys
you know obviously are very good at what
they do but they don't look like regular
athletes like what if a regular athlete
started playing golf i think that was
what tiger did yeah tiger tiger changed
the game on so many levels he made golf
an event i would watch golf with my dad
on the phone and we'd watch tiger play
i got to say this too though is that
tiger was so powerful he had so much
torque that that's why he's having back
problems now and so you wonder with a
guy like bryson by the way bryson just
lost a bunch of weight he looks [ __ ]
amazing this is a video is this
australia no when they're attacking the
police this is what tiger blocking it
looks the same almost but yeah when he
was walking up 18 the people were going
so nuts that what kind of security is
this this is [ __ ] they tried what's
that guy behind him with his arms out
[ __ ] put your arms down there's [ __ ]
40 000 people and one guy and they're
all drunk
and they're all hammered
and you gotta remember he was luckily
they're golf people
right oh golf people movie savages that
doesn't mean much yeah golf people could
be savage domino's fans because they're
mostly just drunk guys see we got so so
rugby fans john daly came in first john
daly came in first he came as an amateur
in the us open correct and came in and
started hitting these monster drives
like 350 375 and everyone rallied and he
had a mullet he was like theo vaughn but
fat and blonde right god man he is a
cigarette in his mouth look at this
cigarette in his mouth
i mean dang a real
gangster in golf i mean when you say
well we turn florida because if he's not
i'll be depressed oklahoma
close enough if you say yeah if you say
hero that's one of my heroes right there
right so john daly comes in starts
hitting monster drives and everyone's
everyone's on the tee box going
rip it john grip and rip it now i know
why you're into patty patty pembleton go
to that picture
yeah
that one down there down there to the
right-hand side to the right-hand side
all the way over all the way over here
yeah no right there right above that one
oh my bad sorry back yeah with the goofy
that one that is
look at that smiling in florida's face
he was denied his true birthright of
florida dude someone [ __ ] up you
should have been born in florida someone
came a sponsor came to him and said
three million dollars we want to send
you to rehab though and he looked at me
and said i'm good and took a sip dude
can i tell you joe when i say so tpc
1997
he's in uh in saint augustine right i
think he went into rehab right after
this if i'm not mistaken
all right should have taken the money
no no no tpc 1997 i'm about to come out
and rolling stone is the number one
party animal in the country and we are
in saint augustine partying our balls
off and john daly's at a bar and we just
see him you're there you saw him in the
bar and and we were like hey man daley
seen drinking on night before he
withdrew we were you were there we were
we i almost jumped in that [ __ ] on on
hole 17 naked i almost jumped in it was
thank god i didn't wait a minute so
you're there
drinking with john daly the night before
he withdraws the night of the event the
night he's out of being too drunk in st
augustine and jacksonville i mean we
were pretty we were pretty drunk also
jack speech jack speech and uh but the
tournaments in st augustine if i'm not
mistaken and so we all went out to see
that and john daly's there and everybody
remember buddies hit me like that's john
daly and he and all i remember out of
that whole [ __ ] night was he was
and i know that he'd withdrew the next
day but he was so accessible he was so
nice
he was not being an [ __ ] he was
having fun he was having a good time and
he's a professional athlete and i
remember thinking
everyone and i was like i was like
that's the guy i want to be like that's
the guy says right here he kept the
crowd going
o'neal said it was obvious he was there
to have a good time
by the time he left
he definitely was feeling very little
pain
[Laughter]
this guy man this guy is
he was like
i would go to golf tournaments with my
dad to watch this guy play because wow
because he would come in
i mean it was a little touch and go
sometimes it'd be a little shaky you
know because he hammered hammered the
night before and sometimes he just
[ __ ] destroy and it was nothing more
fun to watch him just do you think that
influenced your future choices 100
percent
but not i mean a hundred mi
this is funny do you know the story
about you and tom when you were playing
tennis against each other no
wait why
tom hired a coach
oh and tom worked with his coach
and he was practicing with this coach
and the coach said listen you got your
fundamentals down you're doing great he
goes this guy's drinking all night he's
like unless he's some sort of [ __ ]
john daly type dude and tom goes no no
no he's exactly a john daly type dude he
goes then the coach goes
oh
[ __ ] and then you showed up with a
[ __ ] somewhere
out of nowhere see me get video of this
the the tennis match it's got to be
online out of nowhere you got a legit
division one serve like who the [ __ ]
saw this coming burke chrysler has a
legit division one tennis serve
and you just [ __ ] smoked those balls
past tommy bunch oh my god he was in
such agony oh he was so bummed out he
was so sad i remember his son showed up
and they made him leave early because he
didn't want his son to see it did you at
any point in time think of yelling out
to him you should have stuck to the
dance-off no
dude i
remember watching him not be able to
return it was like awkward like it
wasn't it wasn't even hitting the
strings on his racket it would hit the
handle and shoot up in the air you have
a sick serve it's crazy it's crazy like
if you develop that thing like some
dudes are just really good at shooting
[ __ ] three-pointers you know there's
like guys just have this touch and you
watch them doing like what the [ __ ] how
are you doing that watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify